Hi. It's Ira Glass recording this in 2006. And the show that you're about to listen to, the fifth episode of our show, we actually can not find a master copy of, and so what you're going to hear is a copy off of somebody's old cassette of this show. And we apologize for the sound quality.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯，这是2006年的录音。你们即将收听的这期节目是我们节目的第五集，但我们实际上已经找不到母带了。所以你们现在听到的是一份从某人当年的旧磁带上翻录的版本。对于音质问题，我们深表歉意。
We all know what liberalism looked like back in its heyday, back during the Kennedy administration and the Great Society. We all can see it. There is President Kennedy on the White House lawn in a sweatshirt playing touch football or taking a pause while playing touch football. He's turning toward the camera. This little film of sweat on his forehead, and he's smiling. And looking, just radiating sexual charisma.
我们都知道自由主义在其鼎盛时期，即肯尼迪政府和“伟大社会”时期是什么样子。我们都能想象那个画面：肯尼迪总统在白宫草坪上穿着运动衫打橄榄球，或者在打球间隙停下来。他转向镜头，额头上挂着细密的汗珠，面带微笑，浑身散发着性魅力。
The heyday of liberalism meant a nation increasingly open about sexuality. It was a time of rising sex on ads and sex on television and increasing sexual frankness in society in general. Now, in our current moment of the Republican revolution, we're a nation that is increasingly getting in touch with our anger. Anger sells. Anger motivates voters. Anger is the engine behind 1,000 talk radio programs. 2,000, 5,000. But not this one, because from WBEZ in Chicago, it's Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass.
自由主义的鼎盛时期意味着一个国家对性观念变得日益开放。那时，广告和电视节目中性元素不断增加，社会对性话题的直率程度也普遍提升。而现在，在我们当前这个“共和革命”的时刻，我们这个国家正越来越频繁地接触到自己的愤怒。愤怒好卖，愤怒能激发选民，愤怒是成千上万个谈话广播节目的核心驱动力。两千、五千个节目皆是如此。但我们的节目例外，因为这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《你的广播剧场》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Wasn't that very Saturday Night Live ? I got so excited when I did it, you could barely understand the call letters, I bet. Just in case  you missed, they were from WBEZ. That's so management doesn't call me up. It's important to them.
这听起来是不是很像《周六夜现场》？我刚才做这段的时候太激动了，我敢说你们几乎听不清电台呼号。以防万一你们错过了，那是WBEZ电台。这样管理层就不会打电话找我麻烦了，这事儿对他们很重要。
Anyway, tonight on our little radio show, civilization and its discontents, and the people who are discontent with the discontents. And if that doesn't make any sense, just stay with us. Just stay with us. Coming up in our program, stories from Larry Steeger, Iris Moore, Cheryl Trykv, and more, more, more.
总之，今晚在我们的广播节目里，我们要探讨文明及其不满，以及那些对这些“不满”感到不满的人。如果这听起来让人费解，请继续收听。请务必留下。节目稍后，我们将带来拉里·斯蒂格、艾里斯·摩尔、谢丽尔·特里夫等人的精彩故事。
So anger, anger is an inherent part of the current conservative revolution. It is built into it from the start. It is front-loaded. It's in the hard drive, hard-wire mechanism of the thing. In the 1980s, when Newt Gingrich was making videotapes and audiotapes for Republican candidates who were trying to win office, and Newt was trying to convince them to win office in the way that he had-- and was very successful in building the Republican majority, as you know, this way-- one of the things that he told them was to consciously use words and phrases that would polarize the political debate, and that would get people angry.
愤怒是当前保守派革命中不可或缺的一部分。它从一开始就内置于其中，是预装好的。它就在这个事物的硬盘和核心机制里。在20世纪80年代，当纽特·金里奇为试图赢得职位的共和党候选人制作录像带和录音带时，他试图说服他们以他那种方式赢得选举——如你们所知，这种方式非常成功地建立了共和党的多多数派——他告诉他们的一件事，就是要有意识地使用那些能使政治辩论两极分化、能让人愤怒的词汇和短语。
This past October, there was this huge profile of his political strategy in The New Yorker . And as it pointed out, the recommended words from these tapes, the recommended words that candidates were supposed to use as often as possible in referring to Democrats, included these words, sick, traitors, corrupt, bizarre, cheat, steal, devour, self-serving-- I'm just trying to get the music ready for this dramatic moment here, I'm setting up-- self-serving, and criminal rights.
去年十月，《纽约客》杂志曾对其政治策略做过一篇详细报道。正如文中指出的，这些录音带中推荐使用的词汇，即候选人在提到民主党人时应尽可能频繁使用的词，包括：病态的、叛徒、腐败的、怪异的、欺诈、偷窃、贪婪、自私自利——我只是在为这个戏剧性的时刻准备配乐，我在做铺垫——以及“刑事权利”。
See, wasn't that worth it, when the music came in right there? Sick, traitors, corrupt, bizarre, cheat, steal, devour, self-serving, and criminal rights. I wonder if it's possible to use all those in one sentence? I'm just looking at the words here. Sick traitors-- I guess I've got to use Democrat. Sick Democratic traitors, with their corrupt and bizarre ways, not only cheat and steal and devour-- It's not a very interesting sentence.
看，音乐刚好在那个时候切入，这不是很值吗？病态的、叛徒、腐败的、怪异的、欺诈、偷窃、贪婪、自私自利，还有“刑事权利”。我在想把这些词放在同一个句子里是不是可行？我正在看这些词。病态的叛徒——我想我得加上“民主党人”。“病态的民主党叛徒，用他们腐败而怪异的方式，不仅欺诈、偷窃和贪婪……”这句子不怎么有趣。
All right, I'll tell you what. We are a radio program. And we have the power to do the following thing. And I'm just going to stop the music. Yeah, there we go. Because this is such a dramatic moment here.
好吧，我告诉你们。我们是个广播节目，我们有权做以下事情。我现在就把音乐停掉。对了，就是这样。因为这确实是一个非常戏剧性的时刻。
Here's what we're going to do. Get a piece of paper and a pencil. I'm going to read you these words. And we'll give you the address of the radio show at the end the program. And whoever can come up with an interesting, grammatically correct sentence using these words, will win a valuable prize. All right, here are the words, sick, traitors, corrupt, bizarre, cheat-- people all over the city are just like cursing me out now. Go slower-- steal, devour, self-serving, and criminal rights. And the winner will get-- I don't know-- a coffee mug, or-- I don't know-- a seat in some congressional district yet to be named.
我们要这么做：拿出一张纸和一支笔。我会把这些词念给你们听。节目最后我们会给出电台地址。谁能用这些词写出一个有趣且语法正确的句子，就能赢取一份贵重的奖品。好了，词汇如下：病态的、叛徒、腐败的、怪异的、欺诈——全城的人现在肯定在骂我了。慢点念——偷窃、贪婪、自私自利，还有“刑事权利”。获胜者将得到……我不知道……一个咖啡杯，或者……一个尚未命名的国会选区的席位。
Let's just be fair here for a second, just a moment of fairness. Cultivating anger amongst the voters is not just a tactic used by conservatives. I would say pretty much the last, oh, you know, 100 years-- let's call it an even 100-- that's been pretty much a mainstay strategy of the left too, to cultivate outrage. Except when the left does it, it is to cultivate outrage at the rich, at business. Which, as we know, is very different from our current political moment. That same New Yorker profile, basically, outlines this whole political strategy to cultivate anger of middle class people against the poor. Not against the rich, but against the poor, and against social programs for the poor.
咱们公平一点，哪怕就一瞬间。煽动选民的愤怒不仅仅是保守派使用的策略。我想说，在过去的，哦，你知道，100年里——咱们就算它整整100年吧——煽动愤慨也基本上是左派的一贯策略。只不过当左派这样做时，是为了煽动对富人和企业的愤慨。这与我们当前的政治时刻有着本质的不同。同样是那篇《纽约客》的人物报道，概述了这种煽动中产阶级对穷人不满的完整政治策略。不是对富人不满，而是对穷人，以及对针对穷人的社会项目不满。
At one point in this article, one of the consultants who holds seminars for House Republicans at the invitation of Speaker Gingrich, this consultant tells the reporter-- All right, I'm going to read from the article.
在这篇文章的某处，一位应众议院议长金里奇邀请为共和党众议员举办研讨会的顾问告诉记者——好吧，我来读读这篇文章。
"Spitting his words and gesturing angrily at his chin, the consultant says, the middle class has had it up to here with the arrogance of the poor and the disenfranchised."
“这位顾问唾沫横飞地挥动手臂，指着下巴说道：‘中产阶级对穷人和被剥夺权利者的傲慢已经忍无可忍了。’”
And one thing that is particular about the current moment in our political life as a nation is that people are angry, but they're not angry at things that are happening to them. What they're getting paid, work conditions down at the factory, the garbage pickup on the street, this isn't what this particular political revolution is trying to instill. This particular revolution is trying to instill anger at welfare moms. People are angry at the O.J. Verdict. They are angry at people who they never met.
我们国家当前政治生活的一个特点是，人们感到愤怒，但他们愤怒的对象并非针对自身遭遇的困境。他们的薪水、工厂的工作条件、街头的垃圾清理，这些并不是这场特定政治革命试图煽动的内容。这场革命试图煽动的是对福利领救济金母亲的愤怒。人们对辛普森案的判决感到愤怒。他们对一些从未谋面的人感到愤怒。
Which brings us to the Susan Smith trial. I know that's kind of a non sequitur. Just ride with me here for a minute. I know a lot of you are working on your words. So this would be a time to really pay attention. The Susan Smith trial is this grisly, grisly, grisly case. And to review briefly, in the small town of Union, South Carolina, Susan Smith locked her two children-- very, very, young children-- into her car and then sank the car in a lake, supposedly, to help her keep this rich boyfriend, who, supposedly, didn't want any children, didn't want her to have kids. And really horrifying story.
这就引出了苏珊·史密斯案。我知道这有点离题。请先跟着我的思路走。我知道你们很多人还在琢磨那些词，所以现在是集中注意力的好时候。苏珊·史密斯案是一起非常、非常、非常惨无人道的案件。简单回顾一下，在南卡罗来纳州的小镇尤宁，苏珊·史密斯把她两个年幼的孩子锁在车里，然后把车沉进湖中。据说，这是为了留住那个富有的男朋友，因为对方据说不想要孩子，也不想让她有孩子。这是一个极其恐怖的故事。
And one of the contributing editors to this radio show, Jack Hitt, he's from South Carolina. And he's a journalist. He's an editor. He's been an editor, anyway, at Harper's Magazine . He's a frequent contributor to the The New York Times , and Esquire , and other places. And over the course of the Susan Smith trial, he traveled home to South Carolina a number of times. And watching the coverage on South Carolina television, he said that what struck him was the pure rage that people had toward Susan Smith. Here he is talking about it.
本节目的特约编辑之一杰克·希特来自南卡罗来纳州。他是一位记者，也是位编辑，曾在《哈珀杂志》担任编辑。他是《纽约时报》、《时尚先生》等媒体的常客。苏珊·史密斯案审判期间，他曾多次回南卡罗来纳州老家。在观看南卡罗来纳州电视台的报道时，他说让他印象深刻的是人们对苏珊·史密斯纯粹的愤怒。以下是他的讲述。
What this town wanted to do was rip her apart. Baby killing bitch, I remember hearing a woman on TV shouting this at the top of her lungs. People were sending in their milk money to help defray the cost of electrocuting her. Perhaps the most horrific image was to see this town of good Christians sort of gathering at the police station door when she was first brought out for a hearing.
小镇上的人们恨不得把她撕碎。我记得在电视上听到一个女人歇斯底里地大喊：“杀婴的贱货！”人们甚至捐出买牛奶的钱，希望能分摊掉对她执行电刑的费用。最恐怖的画面莫过于，当她第一次被带出来参加听证会时，那个小镇上善良的基督徒们在警察局门口聚集的场景。
And the crowd actually rushed the deputies to try to get to her. The deputies had to lock arms to stop the crowd from ripping her apart.
人群甚至冲向副警长，试图接近她。副警长们不得不挽起手臂，才挡住了这群想把她撕碎的人。
He said that this reaction is understandable at the beginning. He said that when he first heard about this case, I mean, his blood ran cold. But he said the thing about this anger was that it never let up. He said that weeks went by, week after week, and it just stayed at fever pitch. And Jack Hitt said that, at that point, he realized that this is typical of a certain kind of conservative today. This is a political style, for good or bad, that we're seeing a lot of in our country right now.
他说这种反应在起初是可以理解的。他说当他第一次听说这个案子时，整个人都毛骨悚然。但他认为，问题的关键在于这种愤怒从未减弱。他说几周过去了，情况依然处于狂热状态。杰克·希特当时意识到，这是当今某些保守派的典型特征。这是一种政治风格，无论好坏，我们现在在全国范围内看到了很多。
Every time you tune them in-- whether it's the McLaughlin Group on Sunday morning, or whatever-- they're still furious. They're just angry, angry, angry, angry, angry. And once the Susan Smith trial drops off the radar, they go pick up something else that will inflame their anger. So they can move on, and hate something else, and be angry, angry, angry at somebody else.
每次你收听他们的节目——无论是周日上午的《麦克劳克林小组》还是其他节目——他们依然处于愤怒之中。他们就是愤怒、愤怒、愤怒、愤怒、愤怒。一旦苏珊·史密斯案从公众视野中消失，他们会立刻寻找别的东西来煽动愤怒，这样他们就能继续前进，去憎恨别的东西，对别人感到愤怒、愤怒、愤怒。
So Jack Hitt wrote an article for The Washington Post . This was an op-ed piece. And in this piece he argued for a different kind of response to the Susan Smith trial. What he said was, sure, she should be punished. He said, we all can agree that she should be punished and severely punished. But he said, even in this case, even in a case so horrible that no one could possibly sympathize with the criminal-- what could be worse than a mother killing her two young children? He said, even in this case, we have to have empathy. The anger has to turn to an attempt to understand why she did what she did and to forgive her.
于是杰克·希特为《华盛顿邮报》写了一篇评论文章。他主张对苏珊·史密斯案采取不同的回应方式。他说，当然，她应该受到惩罚。他说我们都同意她应该受到惩罚，而且是严厉的惩罚。但他认为，即使是在这样一个恐怖到没人能同情罪犯的案件中——还有什么比母亲杀死两个年幼的孩子更糟糕的呢？——即使是在这种情况下，我们也必须拥有同理心。愤怒应当转化为一种试图理解她为何这么做的尝试，并宽恕她。
He wrote in his piece, "If there's one aspect of the old liberalism that should be preserved during its excommunication, it's the willingness to contemplate even the most horrific and to seek to understand why things happen."
他在文中写道：“如果说旧的自由主义在被排挤的过程中还有什么值得保留的一面，那就是那种愿意审视即使是最可怕的事情，并试图理解事情为何发生的心态。”
What we understand as we come to know Susan Smith more, and more, and more, is that rather than it being the story of a sort of libertine, promiscuous woman who wanted to have her way and wanted to have her rich husband and, therefore, killed her children so she could have this husband who didn't want to have any children. It became a much more complicated story, less of a cartoon story, more of a sort of human story. And let me just give you that very briefly.
当我们越来越深入地了解苏珊·史密斯时，我们发现这并非一个放荡、淫乱的女人为了私欲、为了留住不想要孩子的富人丈夫而杀害孩子的故事。它变成了一个复杂得多的故事，不再是一个漫画式的桥段，更像是一个人性的悲剧。我简要地复述一下。
Her mother, Linda, was married to a fireman, and eventually divorced him, and married a sort of richer man, Beverly Russell. And after a few years, when Susan's 13, she tries to kill herself. That happens, it passes. When she's 16, she goes to a high school guidance counselor to say that her stepfather, Mr. Russell, a member of the Christian Coalition and a Republican county chairman, is abusing her.
她的母亲琳达曾嫁给一名消防员，后来离婚，又嫁给了一个更有钱的男人——贝弗利·拉塞尔。几年后，苏珊13岁时尝试自杀，但这事儿过去了。16岁时，她向学校辅导员举报，称她的继父、基督教联盟成员兼共和党县主席拉塞尔先生正在猥亵她。
Russell comes in. He basically admits to this. Mom says, I'll handle this. We don't need to go public. We don't need to bring any charges. I'll handle this at home. Nothing happened. And everybody went back home and went back to what they were doing. We now know that Mr. Russell went back to abusing his stepdaughter. A year after that, Susan tried to kill herself again, was institutionalized. After that, she graduates from high school. She gets pregnant by this young man, has the first of the two boys. And finally, at age 23, she commits this unspeakable act.
拉塞尔来了，他基本承认了。母亲说：“我会处理的，不需要公之于众，不需要提起指控，我会在家里处理。”什么都没发生。大家都回到家，恢复了原本的生活。我们现在知道，拉塞尔先生继续猥亵他的继女。一年后，苏珊再次自杀未遂，被送进疗养院。后来她高中毕业，与一名年轻人生下长子，接着是第二个。最终，在23岁时，她犯下了那起令人发指的罪行。
So this op-ed piece is published, in which Jack Hitt urges that we try to understand and forgive Susan Smith. And you know, a writer wants to have an effect on the public. And after this op-ed piece came out, Jack Hitt did notice one significant change in the general mood of public anger. What he noticed was now some it was directed at him.
所以，那篇呼吁理解和宽恕苏珊·史密斯的评论文章发表后，作为一个希望影响公众的作者，杰克·希特注意到公众愤怒情绪的一个显著变化：现在，其中一些愤怒直接指向了他。
His op-ed piece generated this huge response. He got lots of furious letters. He was used as a punching bag on talk radio, all just ripping into him. Now people who write letters to the editor about a piece like Jack Hitt's, they usually do not get much satisfaction. You're lucky if you get published at all when you write a letter to the editor. And if you are published, you're usually edited. And who knows what will happen to your words. But because so many people disagreed with Jack Hitt, we thought that we would give one of them a chance, here, to discuss it with him directly.
这篇评论文章引发了巨大的反响。他收到了大量愤怒的信件，在谈话广播中被当作靶子抨击。通常情况下，给编辑写信批评像杰克·希特那样的文章的人，很难得到回音。你的信能被发表就已经是幸运了，而且发表时通常会被删改，谁也不知道你的言论会变成什么样。但因为这么多人不同意杰克的观点，我们想给其中一位读者一个机会，让他直接与作者讨论。
And so we invited one of the letter writers to come on the show with him. We think this is a radio first. At least we're going to say that. We have never heard of anybody doing it. And so from now on, we are just going to repeat that for the rest of the show. This is a radio first that we're doing this. OK, good. I'm glad we have that settled.
于是我们邀请了其中一位写信人上节目与他面对面交流。我们认为这在广播史上是首次。至少我们要这么宣传。我们从未听说过有人这样做。从现在开始，节目余下的部分我们将不断重复这一点：这是广播史上的首次尝试。好了，太好了，达成共识了。
The person that we chose, the letter writer that we chose, is named Gregory Baruch, and he's an attorney in Washington, DC. And what he said in his letter, he said, basically, that Jack Hitt overstated the need for forgiveness in this case and understated the need for punishment.
我们选择的写信人叫格雷戈里·巴鲁克，他是华盛顿特区的一名律师。他在信中基本认为，杰克·希特夸大了在这个案件中宽恕的必要性，却淡化了惩罚的必要性。
First of all, it may be that forgiveness is a pretty low priority here. That what we have is a situation where somebody, to some degree, has placed themselves beyond the realm in which we really should be worrying too much about that. Of course, it's a horrible story, Susan Smith's life. But there has got to be a limit to where you forgive. What if her stepfather came in and said, well, I was abused as a kid too, and that's why I had to pass on the cycle of abuse to Susan. Would we then have to hold out forgiveness to him as well?
首先，宽恕在这里可能优先级很低。我们面对的情况是，某人在某种程度上已经超越了我们应当给予关心的界限。当然，苏珊·史密斯的生活是一个悲剧，但宽恕必须有个限度。如果她的继父过来辩解说：“我也曾受过虐待，所以我才会把这种虐待循环传递给苏珊。”那我们是否也必须宽恕他呢？
Can I say something here, Ira?
我能插一句吗，艾拉？
Yeah, sure. Jack Hitt.
当然可以，杰克·希特。
Yes, Mr. Baruch, I would say you should. In fact, you know there's an entire religion founded on this concept called Christianity. And yes, Mr. Baruch, I would say that one way perhaps to break the cycle is to speak of forgiveness. Now, I say that all in the context of, this is not the equivalent of clemency. Forgiveness and clemency are two different concepts. Forgiveness does not mean we let Susan Smith go, or that we eliminate the need for punishment.
是的，巴鲁克先生，我会说你应该宽恕。事实上，你知道有一种宗教就是建立在这个概念之上的，那就是基督教。是的，巴鲁克先生，我想打破这种循环的一种方式或许就是谈论宽恕。现在，我说的这一切是在不等于特赦的前提下。宽恕和特赦是两个不同的概念。宽恕并不意味着我们要放走苏珊·史密斯，也不意味着我们不需要惩罚。
It goes without saying that she deserves, at very least, a lifetime in prison, at the very least. And I say that as a liberal. People who do bad things need punishment, and we need to punish them.
无需多言，她至少应该受到终身监禁的惩罚，这是最起码的。我以自由主义者的身份这样说。做了坏事的人需要惩罚，我们也需要惩罚他们。
Gregory Baruch?
格雷戈里·巴鲁克？
I think what a lot of people are reacting to here is that the liberal view that was most popular in the '60s, it's not inherently necessary for a liberal to take, is sort of a denial that there is evil in the world. And with Beverly Russell, I think what people see is, they see that that's evil, and also with Susan Smith. Now, one thing to keep in mind with Susan Smith is the country saw her over several days on television, tearfully talking about her babies, and how they had been taken away by a black man. And I think that that stuck with people. That what they realized was this was somebody who not only was able to do it, but who was able to do it and then try to get away with it. And that that does not indicate a person who really is deserving of a lot of sympathy.
我认为许多人反感的其实是60年代最流行的那种自由派观点，即否认世界上存在邪恶。对于贝弗利·拉塞尔，我认为人们看到的是恶；对于苏珊·史密斯，人们看到的同样是恶。有一点需要记住，全国人民在电视上看了她好几天，看着她含泪谈论自己的孩子，谈论孩子们是如何被一个黑人抢走的。我认为那深深刺痛了人们。他们意识到这是一个不仅能够做出这种事，而且事后还试图掩盖罪行的人。这说明她并不值得同情。
Jack Hitt?
杰克·希特？
Really, my article is not about Susan Smith. It's about you and me. The punishment issue, you're right, it's about Susan Smith. She deserves to be punished. My point is that the whole idea of forgiveness is about us getting beyond this crime. Otherwise, we all are forced, as I think many conservatives would like us to be, stoking our anger for the rest of all time, so that we can hate this woman forever. And really, my piece is, finally, a kind of secular statement of what Christianity is. That's why I was sort of alarmed that most of the people who reacted with such fury at my piece were themselves alleged Christians.
说实话，我的文章不是关于苏珊·史密斯的，而是关于你和我。惩罚的问题，你是对的，那是关于苏珊·史密斯的，她应当受到惩罚。我的观点是，宽恕的全部意义在于让我们超越这场犯罪。否则，我们所有人都会被迫——我想这也是许多保守派希望我们做的——整天煽动愤怒，好让我们永远憎恨这个女人。归根结底，我的文章其实是对基督教教义的一种世俗化表达。这就是为什么我感到震惊，因为大多数对我文章表现出极大愤怒的人，自称恰恰是基督徒。
Let me ask Mr. Baruch. Do you find persuasive anything in what Jack Hitt says about this notion that, yes, of course, this woman should be punished. But in the case of her, in the case her stepfather, the point of Christianity is that there needs to be empathy and forgiveness.
请问巴鲁克先生，杰克·希特提到的那个观点是否令你信服？即：当然，这个女人应当受到惩罚，但在她和她继父的案例中，基督教的意义在于同理心和宽恕。
Well, obviously, I don't want to be in a theological dispute. But at the same time, there's nothing necessarily bad about people's outrage. That Jesus also said, what you do to the least of my creatures, you do to me. And it's not true that everybody who has a bad home life or who comes from a situation where they were abused has to turn around and do the same thing.
好吧，我不想陷入神学争论。但与此同时，人们的愤怒并非一无是处。耶稣也曾说过，你们对我最小的兄弟所做的，就是对我所做的。并不是每个有糟糕家庭背景或受过虐待的人，都必须转而去伤害别人。
And in fact, what a lot of people, I think, recognize is that the forgiveness culture does not encourage people to choose the right path. It doesn't encourage people to act well. That we may be better off in a culture that asks more of people.
事实上，我认为很多人认识到，“宽恕文化”并不鼓励人们选择正确的道路，也不鼓励人们向善。我们如果身处一个对民众要求更高的文化中，情况可能会更好。
Part of what you're saying in your letter, if I understand it right, is you're impatient with the notion of, we should try to understand people like Susan Smith, and we should try to be empathetic with them. I get the sense that you feel like we've had enough of that.
你信中的部分观点，如果我理解没错的话，是你对“我们应该尝试理解像苏珊·史密斯这样的人，并对他们抱有同理心”这一观念感到不耐烦。我觉得你认为我们已经受够了这一套。
Well, there is something like that. Because the thing is that there is a history here. There's a history in which crime has not been taken as seriously, as it should have been, for many years by a lot of people who place themselves on the left of the political spectrum. And that really, I think, is what people were reacting to so strongly when Michael Dukakis had that famous line. When he was asked what would happen if his wife were raped and murdered, he essentially responded that he would increase drug education in the schools. That people realized that there is a history here where people do see that that may well be where this leads.
确实有这种感觉。因为历史告诉我们，犯罪问题在过去很多年里并未受到应有的重视，尤其是被那些政治立场偏左的人。我认为，当迈克尔·杜卡基斯那句名言出现时，人们反应如此强烈正是因为这个。当被问及如果他的妻子被强奸并谋杀会怎么做时，他本质上回答说他会加强学校的药物教育。人们意识到，这背后存在着历史遗留问题。
Jack Hitt, Gregory Baruch is arguing, essentially, that too much forgiveness, a notion of too much forgiveness, is dangerous for a society. That is, that people cease to take responsibility for their own actions, in a way that even you would want them to.
杰克·希特，格雷戈里·巴鲁克本质上是在争论：过度的宽恕观念对社会是危险的。即人们不再为自己的行为负责，这甚至违背了你想看到的初衷。
I would agree with him on that. I agree that I don't want the idea of forgiveness to mean that we let people go. My argument is that the pendulum has swung so far in the direction of punishment that that's all we care about. Jails, jails, jails, that's the solution to everything. There's a local statute that was just passed that anybody under 18 who gets in trouble, their parents now go to jail. It's the remedy for everything.
在这点上我同意他。我不希望宽恕意味着放走罪犯。我的论点是，天平已经向惩罚的一端倾斜得太远，以至于那成了我们关心的全部。监狱、监狱、监狱，那是所有问题的解决方案。当地刚通过一项法规，任何18岁以下的孩子惹事，他们的父母都要入狱。这成了解决一切的灵丹妙药。
But it seems to me, for us to be able to contemplate the bad things that people do, and the horrible things that happen in our culture, and then to be able to move beyond that requires that we find some way to comprehend and understand these terrible things that happen. And I think that the idea of forgiveness is the right way to go.
但在我看来，如果我们想审视人们所做的坏事，审视文化中发生的恐怖事件，并超越它们，就需要找到某种方式来理解和领悟这些可怕的事情。我认为宽恕是正确的方向。
Let me turn to Gregory Baruch.
请问格雷戈里·巴鲁克？
Well, Mr. Glass, what Mr. Hitt says, is well we shouldn't keep being angry at this. But I don't know that it's a bad thing, when something terrible has been done, to stay angry at it, not to let it fade in our mind. And I don't think it's selfish to do that when it's a bad thing that has been done to somebody else. I like to think that I wouldn't be jaded, that when I hear something terrible, that I will continue thinking it's terrible, and, frankly, that I'll continue being angry about it.
格拉斯先生，希特先生说我们不应该继续保持愤怒。但我并不认为当可怕的事情发生时，保持愤怒是一件坏事，不要让这种愤怒在脑海中淡去。当针对他人的恶行发生时，保持愤怒并不是自私。我希望自己不会变得麻木，当我听到可怕的事情时，我会继续认为那是可怕的，坦白说，我会继续为此感到愤怒。
I can't disagree with you more. I mean, the people who were angry at that courthouse, and who are still angry-- and that's my point-- they sort of dig themselves into this rut of anger and never get out of it. They just stay there in a constant rage. There is no other choice. Like I say, Susan Smith drops off the radar this week, don't worry.
我完全不同意你的看法。在法院外那些愤怒的人——他们现在依然愤怒，这正是我的观点——他们陷入了愤怒的死胡同中无法自拔。他们始终处于暴怒中。别无选择。就像我说的，苏珊·史密斯案这周会淡出公众视野，别担心。
Jack Hitt is a writer, now living in Connecticut. Gregory Baruch is an attorney in Washington, DC.
杰克·希特是一位现居康涅狄格州的作家。格雷戈里·巴鲁克是华盛顿特区的一名律师。
As for another model for how to consider this question of punishment and forgiveness, you could also consider the testimony of Susan Smith's stepfather, Beverly Russell. And in this culture of forgiveness, where people go onto talk shows all the time and say, well, sure I did whatever, that bad whatever that I did. Sure I did that. I had a reason, though. People are constantly saying, I had a reason. It was my parents. It was my upbringing. Beverly Russell said, no, no, no. The buck stops here. He said that by sexually abusing his stepdaughter for all those years, by doing that, he said, he was guilty, not just for what he did to her, but for what she did to her two sons.
关于思考惩罚与宽恕问题的另一种视角，你可以参考苏珊·史密斯继父贝弗利·拉塞尔的证词。在这个宽恕文化中，人们总是上谈话节目说：“是的，我确实做了那些糟糕的事，但我有理由。”人们不断在说“我有理由”，是父母的原因，是成长环境的原因。贝弗利·拉塞尔则说：“不，不，不。责任在我。”他说，多年来通过性虐待继女，他不仅要对自己对待她的方式负责，还要对她后来对待两个儿子的方式负责。
In his testimony he said, "You don't have all the guilt in this tragedy." At that point he cried, apparently, on the stand. He said, "Had I been true to you and my responsibilities, you would have been stronger in yourself, not needing to be constantly supported and reassured emotionally. My heart breaks for what I've done to you, for your pain and loss. Had I known at the time the result of my sin, I could have mustered enough strength to assume my responsibilities."
他在证词中说：“这场悲剧的罪责并不全在你。”说到这里，他在证人席上哭了。他说：“如果我忠于你并承担起责任，你本会变得更坚强，不需要不断的精神支柱和抚慰。我因我对你所做的一切，因你的痛苦和损失而心碎。如果我当时知道我罪行的后果，我本可以鼓起足够的勇气去承担我的责任。”
Polls show that in the little town of Union, South Carolina, where Susan Smith and Beverly Russell live-- or where Susan Smith lived before she was put in prison-- in that town, 75% of the residents have agreed with the jury's decision against the death penalty in her case. They decided for the more lenient penalty of life in prison. In the country as a whole, further away from the human reality of these people's lives, 75% of the population believes that she should get the death penalty.
民意调查显示，在苏珊·史密斯和贝弗利·拉塞尔居住的小镇尤宁，75%的居民支持陪审团对她做出的免除死刑的判决。他们选择了较轻的终身监禁。而在全国范围内，远离这些当事人现实生活的人群中，75%的人认为她应该被判死刑。
I'm sorry for what I've done. I realize that it is premature and also at a very late stage in the game for me to be coming forth. But to come forth is an action, which should take place. I apologize for being taller than the person sitting behind me. I apologize for being smaller than the person sitting in front of me.
我为我所做的一切感到抱歉。我意识到现在道歉显得为时过早，而且为时已晚。但道歉是一种行动，它必须发生。我为我比坐在我身后的人个子高而道歉。我为我比坐在我前面的人个子矮而道歉。
I relinquish nothing and everything in order to stand here before you. And this I apologize for. I do not believe that this will allow me to enter into any new situation without the remembrance of what I've done. I only wish for you to hear me. I apologize for this also. I'm sorry.
我舍弃一切也一无所获，只为了站在这里。对此我道歉。我不认为这能让我进入任何新的境地而不去铭记我的所作所为。我只想让你们听我说。对此我也表示歉意。我很抱歉。
I have brought shame on my family. I've caused anguish, hurt, pain, and suffering in other families. I've done things which should not have been done. Without naming names, I have provoked, qualified, justified, revoked, interred, summoned, questioned, realized, created, allowed, returned, configured, situated, and muted things I should not have.
我给我的家庭带来了耻辱。我给其他家庭造成了痛苦、伤害、悲痛和苦难。我做了不该做的事。在不指名道姓的情况下，我诱导、界定了、辩解了、撤销了、埋葬了、召唤了、质疑了、意识到、创造了、允许了、归还了、配置了、安置了、并压制了我不该做的事。
I will allow for a return of the things that I have taken. They are not mine. They have never belonged to me. And if they could all be restored with no knowledge of me ever possessing or adjusting them, I could regain footing and a holding in this world that I do not or should not belong to.
我将允许我索取过的事物回归。它们不属于我。它们从未属于过我。如果它们能在不被知晓的情况下复原，我或许能在这个我不属于或不该属于的世界里重新获得立足之地。
If I am misunderstood, you have only me to blame. I do not warrant this voice. I give this back. I do not hold this ground. It is not mine to stand on. Your hearing is the only thing I have left. And I apologize for this. It is not mine to possess.
如果我被误解了，那只能怪我。我不配拥有这声音。我把它还回去。我不占有这片土地。我不该站在这里。你们的倾听是我仅存的唯一事物。对此我表示歉意。它不属于我所能占有。
Every time you say my name, my body's resistance breaks in a column from the surface of my skin to the bone. But I forgive you. I forgive myself. I forgive my past. I forgive my name. I forgive my family. I forgive my anatomy. I forgive everything until I am totally blank. I have no memory at all. All my questions have been answered. The missing link has been found. All is forgiven. Come home.
每当你叫我的名字，我的身体阻抗就会从皮肤表面裂开到骨头。但我原谅你。我原谅我自己。我原谅我的过去。我原谅我的名字。我原谅我的家庭。我原谅我的生理构造。我原谅一切，直到我变得一片空白。我没有任何记忆。我所有的问题都已得到解答。缺失的一环已被找到。一切皆被原谅。回家吧。
Performance artists Iris Moore and Larry Steeger. Larry's piece was based on the testimony of serial murderer Jeffrey Dahmer. This is Your Radio Playhouse from WBEZ Chicago. Now this artifact of the forgiveness culture.
行为艺术家艾里斯·摩尔和拉里·斯蒂格。拉里的作品基于连环杀手杰弗里·达默的证词。这是芝加哥WBEZ的《你的广播剧场》。现在，让我们看看这个宽恕文化的产物。
[MUSIC - "I BLAME GOD"]
[音乐 - “我责怪上帝”]
Well the views expressed in the music on this program are not those of WBEZ management or the program's funders. So whatever you think of this notion that our society needs to be less forgiving, that we need to be harsher with people, so they do what's right and not what's wrong. But if you think about this philosophically, you have to acknowledge that it has practical consequences as social policy.
本节目音乐中表达的观点不代表WBEZ管理层或节目资助方的意见。无论你如何看待“社会需要减少宽恕、更严厉对待民众以确保其行事正确”这一观点，如果你从哲学角度思考，你必须承认这作为社会政策会产生实际后果。
These kinds of ideas have, basically, led to a dramatic toughening of many criminal statutes in many states across the country. We've seen a spate, over the last year, over the last few years, of increases in mandatory sentences, accountability laws, lots of laws, trying juveniles as adults when they commit certain crimes.
这些理念基本上导致了全国许多州刑事法规的剧烈收紧。过去几年里，我们看到了一系列强制刑期、问责法律的增加，以及许多针对未成年人犯罪的成人化审判法律。
And in a certain sense, these laws are working. The murder rate is down in many big cities, including Chicago and New York. The prison population has skyrocketed, people are being taken off the street, more men are being locked up for more years. But to give a sense of some of the human consequences of this, here's Darrin Bowden, a supervising attorney with the public defenders office in Cook County.
从某种意义上说，这些法律是有效的。包括芝加哥和纽约在内的许多大城市的谋杀率正在下降。监狱人口暴增，更多的人被带离街头，更多男人被判处更长刑期。但为了让大家感受一下这背后的人性代价，请听库克郡公设辩护人办公室的主管律师达林·鲍登的讲述。
A young man I was seeing, for the record, his name is J.B., a 13 year old who was a ward of the court, because his mother was a substance abuser. His father was nowhere to be found. The only one who embraced this young man was the gang, the dope pusher. 13 years old, began selling narcotics. And--
记录在案，我曾经接触过一个年轻人，他的名字是J.B.，一个13岁的法院监护少年，因为他的母亲是药物滥用者。他的父亲不知所踪。唯一接纳这个少年的只有帮派和毒贩。13岁就开始贩毒，然后——
Hi, Ira Glass here, talking to you again. Remember, about 30 minutes ago, I said that this is an old cassette copy of one of our programs? Well, this is actually the point in the program where the person needed to flip over the cassette. And what's about to happen is that in going to the other side, apparently, a word or two got cut off. And we think the word that got cut off is the word, someone. So I'm just going to say it for you now. Someone--
嗨，我是艾拉·格拉斯，又在跟你说话了。记得大约30分钟前，我说过这是一盘旧磁带的录音吗？其实这正是在节目中需要翻转磁带的时刻。接下来发生的事情是，在切换到另一面时，似乎漏掉了一两个词。我们认为那个词是“有人”。所以我现在帮你补上。有人——
Stole his narcotics. His life was on the line. And he was threatened that if you do not either get the money, the drugs, or get the individual who stole the drugs, not only will your life be in jeopardy, but your sister's life will be in jeopardy. And, basically surviving, J.B. pulls a trigger, takes a human life. And yes, he should be held responsible for that.
偷了他的毒品。他生命垂危。他受到威胁，如果他不交出钱、毒品或者揪出那个偷毒品的人，不仅他的生命不保，连他姐姐的命也会有危险。为了生存，J.B.扣动了扳机，夺走了一条生命。是的，他确实应该为此负责。
But where we erred, we were not concerned and compassionate enough to understand why it took place. In doing that, we sent a 13 year old boy to the adult system, where he was sentenced by a judge, who is an elected official, to 55 years. Treated as an adult, and being treated as an adult, receiving adult time.
但我们犯错的地方在于，我们没有足够关心和同情去理解这背后发生的一切。正因如此，我们将一个13岁的男孩送进了成人司法系统，被一名民选法官判处55年刑期。他被当作成年人对待，承受着成人的惩罚。
J.B. is now 15 years of age. J.B. will be in his late thirties or early forties, I believe, when he's released, with no hope of receiving a job, because he's a convicted felon, convicted of murder. That record will follow him forever.
J.B.现在15岁。我相信在他获释时将是三四十岁的中年人，而且因为他是被判重罪的杀人犯，没有任何工作机会。那个案底会跟随他一生。
And if we had moved in the true spirit of the Juvenile Court Act, we would have decided that, hey, this is a young man who never had an opportunity, let's provide him with an opportunity. And that opportunity might have been, yes, we're going to send him to the juvenile Department of Corrections.
如果我们遵循《青少年法院法》的精神，我们本可以决定：嘿，这是一个从未得到过机会的年轻人，让我们给他一个机会。那个机会可能是，是的，把他送进少年教管所。
But unlike the adult Department of Corrections, there are services, schools, counselors, the ratio between students and teachers. And try to help this individual, upon his release-- at the age of 21, 19 years of age-- provide that individual with an opportunity to make something of himself, to reintroduce him into society, to understand that he is a child. And that's all he was. He is a child. You may say that he performed an adult act. But when you're a child, you speak and act as a child.
但与成人监狱不同的是，教管所里有服务、学校、辅导员，以及师生比例的保障。努力去帮助这个人在他19岁或21岁获释后，给他一个重新做人的机会，让他重返社会，去理解他仅仅是个孩子。他只是个孩子。你可以说他执行了成人的行为，但当你是孩子时，你的言行就像个孩子。
Darrin Bowden, from the public defenders office here in Cook County. This next song is from Johnny Cash's album recorded at Folsom Prison and San Quentin.
以上是来自库克郡公设辩护人办公室的达林·鲍登。下一首歌来自约翰尼·卡什在福尔松监狱和圣昆汀监狱录制的专辑。
[MUSIC - "THE WALL," JOHNNY CASH]
[音乐 - “墙”，约翰尼·卡什]
Johnny Cash, Your Radio Playhouse . Glen Fitzgerald sees all this from another angle.
约翰尼·卡什，这里是《你的广播剧场》。格伦·菲茨杰拉德从另一个角度看待这一切。
By the way, if you are trying to think about doing those words that we said earlier in the show, that is, create one sentence. Our very first radio contest here. Create one sentence, grammatical sentence, an interesting sentence we hope, using these words. The words are sick-- got a pencil, got a pencil-- sick, traitors, corrupt, bizarre, cheat, steal, devour, self-serving, and criminal rights. And get the word Democrat in there too, just for good measure. And if you didn't hear the beginning of the show, we're not even going to explain it. It's too complicated.
顺便提一下，如果你还在尝试写我们节目开头提到的那句话，即创造一个句子。这是我们在这儿举办的第一个广播竞赛。创造一个句子，语法正确，有趣，希望如此，使用这些词。词汇是：病态的（准备好笔了吗？准备好了吗？）——病态的、叛徒、腐败的、怪异的、欺诈、偷窃、贪婪、自私自利，以及“刑事权利”。顺便加上“民主党人”，以示完整。如果你没听到节目开头，我们就不再解释了，太复杂了。
So Glen Fitzgerald sees all this from a different angle, these questions of forgiveness. He's a missionary with Youth for Christ, Chicago Metro Youth for Christ. And he works with gang members. And for a lot of his job-- for all of his job, actually-- he tries to bring gang members over to the Lord. And spends a lot of time in the prisons, in the jails, and a lot of time on the streets. But as part of his job, he goes out to suburban churches and does public speaking, partly to tell people about what the ministry is able to do, in terms of turning boys around, and partly to raise money sometimes. And occasionally he takes some boys with him. But he says that when he goes out and talks to these suburbanites, these mostly white suburbanites, about what goes on in the city, he says the reaction is usually the same.
所以格伦·菲茨杰拉德从不同角度看待这一切，关于宽恕的问题。他是芝加哥都市区青年基督徒组织的传教士。他与帮派成员打交道。为了他的工作——或者说，他工作的全部意义——他试图将帮派成员引向主。他花很多时间在监狱和街头。作为工作的一部分，他经常去郊区的教堂进行演讲，既是为了告诉人们事工在转变少年方面的能力，有时也是为了筹款。偶尔他会带一些少年一起去。但他表示，当他去给这些郊区居民，这些主要是白人的郊区居民谈论城市里发生的事情时，反应通常如出一辙。
You have people being comfortable saying, even in a church setting, these kids really do need to be locked up. These kids, we need to throw away the key on this. Something bad should happen to them. We should punish all this wrongdoing. And yet they never feel that way about the kids that we bring to them. And I'm talking about guys who are really-- these aren't wannabes. These are the real thing, dope dealing, gang violence between the two, what they would call, missions.
即使在教堂环境中，人们也能泰然自若地说：“这些孩子确实需要被关起来，我们需要把钥匙丢掉。他们应该遭遇报应。我们应该惩罚所有这些罪恶。”然而，当他把那些真实的孩子带到他们面前时，他们却从未有过那种感觉。我说的这些家伙是真正的帮派成员——他们不是装模作样，而是真正贩毒、为了所谓“任务”参与帮派暴力的那群人。
So those are the guys I bring in to the  meetings. And they will say to the kid, this is great what you're doing. The same people who, five minutes ago, were line them up and shoot them. I don't care. Lock them up, throw away the key. The same people can instantaneously turn themselves around, when they actually can see this kid. This is great. This we like. Him, we like. This is good. We can do this. But these other kids on the street, that's different. What I was just saying now, forget that. With them, that goes back to what I was saying before about lining them up, and shooting them, and everything.
于是我把这些家伙带到会议上。那些五分钟前还嚷着“把他们排成一排枪毙吧，我不在乎，关起来，把钥匙扔掉”的人，在亲眼见到这些孩子时，却能瞬间改变态度说：“你做的太棒了。这个我们喜欢，那个人我们也喜欢。这很好，我们能做这个。”但是，那些街头上的孩子？那是另外一回事。刚才我说的话？别管它。对他们来说，那又回到了我之前说的排成一排枪毙的那套逻辑。
I think we have to look at what's going on there. We have one consideration for these people who are on the evening news, and another one for the people who are in our lives, in that inner circle of our lives. And it, for whatever reason, is easy to take those people on the evening news and pronounce something ugly should happen to them. But that should never happen to these people in our own inner circle. Well, and I'm there to explain, wait a second, it's really the same thing.
我认为我们必须审视那里到底发生了什么。我们对晚间新闻里报道的那些人有一种审视标准，而对我们生活中内圈的人则有另一套。无论出于什么原因，在晚间新闻里评判那些人，说他们应该遭遇丑陋的后果是容易的。但那绝对不应该发生在我们内圈的人身上。而我在那里是为了解释：“等等，这本质上是一回事。”
I think there's an unfortunate syndrome that many Christians fall prey to, and I'm speaking about my own brothers and sisters. One way or another, I'm still on their side. I still love them. But I got to be honest about what I'm seeing out there. And I think there's an unfortunate tendency to see ourselves, since we've been forgiven, and since we've made some improvements, that we then, therefore, ascended to some lofty position from where we can look down on the rest of humanity and society.
我认为许多基督徒容易陷入一种不幸的综合征，我说的正是我自己的弟兄姐妹。无论如何，我依然站在他们这一边。我依然爱他们。但我必须诚实地面对我所看到的一切。我认为存在一种不幸的倾向：因为我们自己曾得到宽恕，也做出了一些改变，于是我们便升到了某种崇高的地位，从那里俯视人类社会的其余部分。
But of all the people who shouldn't be thinking that way, it's got to be us. What I'm saying is grace is the substance of my relationship with God. It's not a cute idea that's thrown in there. It's not just a really nice aspect. It's the stuff of which it's all about.
但在所有不该有这种想法的人当中，我们肯定是首当其冲。我想说的是，恩典是我与上帝关系的本质。它不是一个随意抛出的可爱概念，也不是一个无关紧要的美好侧面，它是这一切的核心所在。
Glen Fitzgerald, a missionary with Youth for Christ here in Chicago.
格伦·菲茨杰拉德（Glen Fitzgerald），芝加哥青年基督会的传教士。
A conservative will tell you if this guy did a crime, he's lousy, and something bad should happen to him. A liberal will tell you, this person did a really bad thing, because of their parents mistreating them, and something really bad should happen to their parents. Well, eventually, don't you get tired of being mad?
保守派会告诉你，如果这家伙犯了罪，那他就是个烂人，就该遭报应。自由派会告诉你，这个人做了坏事是因为父母虐待他，所以他父母才该遭报应。好吧，说到底，难道你不厌倦这种愤怒吗？
[MUSIC - "GREYSTONE CHAPEL," JOHNNY CASH]
[音乐 - “GREYSTONE CHAPEL”，约翰尼·卡什]
Well, Your Radio Playhouse. Ira Glass here. One sign, perhaps the best sign, of just how widespread in our culture is this idea that we [INTERPOSING MUSIC] When Colin Powell, General Colin Powell, dropped out of the presidential race, on that day in that press conference, he was asked by a reporter, what would you have done if you had become president? And recall, this is a candidate who even was criticized for having views that were so mainstream, so middle of the road, that he alienated no one. So let's listen to what he said.
欢迎收听《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse），我是艾拉·格拉斯。在我们的文化中，这个观念——即我们[音乐插入]——的普及程度，有一个迹象，或许是最好的迹象。当科林·鲍威尔将军（General Colin Powell）宣布退出总统竞选时，在当天的记者招待会上，有记者问他：“如果你当选了总统，你会怎么做？”请记住，这位候选人甚至曾因观点过于主流、过于中庸而未引起任何人的反感。那么，让我们听听他说了什么。
Show leadership. Be a conciliator. Move the country forward toward lower government, less government.
展示领导力，做调停者，推动国家向更小政府、精简政府的方向发展。
OK, so far we're in pretty standard territory for politicians in this country.
好了，到目前为止，我们还在这个国家政客的标准领域内。
Put us in a more fiscally responsible platform basis.
让我们走上一个更具财政责任感的平台基础。
OK, so far absolutely everything is just things you've heard before, very common things in our political culture.
好的，目前为止所说的一切都是你以前听过的，在我们政治文化中非常常见的套话。
And try to inspire people. And try to restore a sense of family, restore a sense of shame in our society.
并尝试激励人们，尝试恢复社会的家庭观念，恢复社会的羞耻感。
That's the one that-- when I read in the paper, restore a sense of shame. Clearly, this is at a point where now everyone-- this is widespread enough that he would just say that in an offhand way. And he didn't even have to explain it or bother. Here's what he said next.
就是这一条——当我在报纸上读到“恢复羞耻感”时。显然，现在大家都到了这个地步——这种说法已经非常普遍了，他可以随口说出来，甚至不需要费心解释。他接下来说了这些。
Help bring more civility into our society.
帮助为我们的社会带来更多的文明。
That's it. Well, at this point in our program, in the interest of equal time, we thought that we would have a story of people who do not have much of a sense of shame in their society, and in fact, are not looking for forgiveness. And in fact, I do not believe would meet the approval of pretty much everybody who we've heard of and heard from so far in the show.
就是这样。好吧，在节目的这个环节，为了平衡起见，我们想讲一个故事，讲讲那些在社会中并没有太多羞耻感的人，事实上，他们并不寻求宽恕。而且我相信，他们不会得到我们在节目中迄今为止听到和提及的大多数人的认可。
We're talking about sinners, basically. Basically, we've had the good people up until this part. And now, we have the part of the show, in the interest of equal time, where we're going to hear about sinners. And one of the things about sin, besides the fact that many sinners are not seeking forgiveness, one of the things that is often underestimated, is that sin is not easy. Sin is not just all fun and games. And this next little story from Cheryl Trykv is pretty much a vivid illustration of what that means, and what it means when you don't seek any kind of forgiveness.
我们谈论的是罪人，基本上就是这样。到目前为止，我们介绍的都是好人。现在进入节目的这一部分，为了平衡起见，我们将听听关于罪人的故事。关于罪的一点——除了许多罪人不寻求宽恕这一事实外——往往被低估的一点是，犯罪并不容易。犯罪不仅仅是寻欢作乐。谢丽尔·特里夫（Cheryl Trykv）的下一个小故事非常生动地说明了这意味着什么，以及当你根本不寻求任何宽恕时意味着什么。
Sally calls and says, Pat has just come home with a big bag of P-O-T, and that maybe I should come over for dinner. Yes, I say, maybe I should. What a friendly gesture, I think to myself, as I dash across the park on my way over. I just met Sally and Pat two nights before at an amiable little tavern up the street on Damon. What a night that was, laughing and joking, crazy photo booth sessions, $0.50 shots of Jagermeister, and a very generous barkeep Sally seemed to know rather well.
莎莉打来电话说，帕特刚带回一大袋大麻，或许我该过去吃晚饭。是的，我说，也许我该去。当我冲过公园前往她家时，我心想，真是个友好的举动。我两天前才在达蒙街上一家友好的小酒馆里见过莎莉和帕特。那真是一个难忘的夜晚，欢声笑语，疯狂的照相亭留影，50美分一杯的野格利口酒，还有一位莎莉似乎很熟的慷慨酒保。
I don't recall much of any conversation that took place that night, just that, well, Sally kept taking off her top, and that everyone was having lots of fun. I cross Damon and turn up Evergreen, where a group of boys wearing Laker jackets man the corner. One of them spits and calls me a yuppie. I'm sure he means this as a joke, so I take no offense. Oh no, I'm quite flattered. He thinks I have insurance, and credit cards, and that I make more than $4,000 a year. Still, I wonder if we don't attach different meanings to the word yuppie. Clearly he means one thing. I mean another. The way bitch, to some, does not mean nasty slut, but rather, hello woman.
我不记得那天晚上说了什么话，只记得莎莉不停地脱掉上衣，大家玩得很开心。我穿过达蒙街，拐上常青路，一群穿着湖人队夹克的小伙子守在街角。其中一个人吐了口唾沫，叫我“雅皮士”。我相信他是在开玩笑，所以我没生气。哦不，我反而觉得受宠若惊。他以为我有保险、有信用卡，而且年薪超过4000美元。尽管如此，我怀疑我们对“雅皮士”这个词的理解是否不同。显然他指一个意思，我指另一个。就像“bitch”这个词，对某些人来说不是指下贱的荡妇，而是指“你好，女士”。
I'd like to illustrate to the young man that he's made a mistake, that I'm not what he thinks I am. And as a matter of fact, I'm on my way to get high, and quite possibly, we share something of a bond. I turn to him and say, all bugs are not cockroaches. Stunned by the relative ease my quick wit shows itself, I continue walking and, in the background behind me, hear someone hocking a loogie.
我想向这位小伙子证明他错了，我不是他认为的那种人。事实上，我正要去吸大麻，很可能我们之间还有某种联系。我转过身对他说：“不是所有的虫子都是蟑螂。”我被自己那机智的回答惊到了，继续走着，身后传来有人吐痰的声音。
Sally is glad to see me, very glad. For dinner she's made her favorite, noodles with pepper and garlic, lots of pepper, lots of garlic. Pat is glad to see me also but is much less physical about it. No juicy lip kisses from Pat. Just a bare chest with two self-piercing nipple rings, a shaved head, and a downward glance that says, hello woman.
莎莉见到我很高兴，非常高兴。为了晚餐，她做了她最喜欢的胡椒大蒜拌面，加了很多胡椒，很多大蒜。帕特见到我也很高兴，但身体语言少得多。帕特没有给我热情的亲吻，只有一个赤裸的胸膛，挂着两个自穿乳环，剃了光头，向下瞥了一眼，仿佛在说“你好，女士”。
Sally sets the dinner table, while Pat puts on some music, a deep, trans-techno, acid, house, hot mix of apocalyptic wonder with 185 beats per minute. Perfect with dinner. Pat seems like he's glad to see me, but I wonder if his selection in music isn't a thinly veiled attack, manifesting his resentment of my coming over to smoke his dope. Still I present myself as the perfect guest.
莎莉摆好餐桌，帕特放起了音乐，一种深沉的、硬核的、工业电音风格的混乱节拍，每分钟185拍。晚餐配这个简直完美。帕特看起来很高兴见到我，但我怀疑他的选曲是对我跑来抽他大麻的一种隐晦攻击，表达了他对我的不满。尽管如此，我还是表现得像个完美的客人。
Pat, I say, at the dinner, this is a stunning tune. Who is this? Oh, do you like it, he says and turns it up, as if it could go any louder. It's Idiot Bliss. Idiot Bliss, oh. They're knew aren't they? No, Pat says. Well, I've got to stop living with my head in a hole, haven't I?
“帕特，”我在晚餐时说，“这首歌太棒了。这是谁的？”“哦，你喜欢吗？”他说着把音量调大，仿佛还能再大声点。“这是Idiot Bliss。”“Idiot Bliss，哦。他们是新出的，对吧？”“不，”帕特说，“好吧，我得停止那种与世隔绝的生活了，不是吗？”
Sally eats her dinner like a little cat-rabbit , nibbling and licking away. I watch her lick her fingers. She licks her knife, and, after that, she licks the serving spoon. I watch her eat and talk at the same time. I got a letter in the mail today from my friend, Miao, in Seattle, she says. She drinks her wine with little laps of the tongue. And how is Meow, I ask? Not Meow, Pat says. Miao, like ciao. Miao. I beg your pardon, Pat.
莎莉吃东西像只小兔猫，一边啃一边舔。我看着她舔自己的手指。她舔刀子，之后又舔了盛菜的勺子。我看着她边吃边说：“今天我收到西雅图朋友缪（Miao）的来信，”她说。她用舌头小口地抿着酒。“‘Meow’怎么样了？”我问。“不是‘Meow’，”帕特说，“是‘Miao’，像‘ciao’那样。Miao。”“抱歉，帕特。”
From the looks of the apartment, I wouldn't have guessed Pat was such a stickler for detail. Sally says, Miao says that if a spaceship comes down for us, we should get on it, because it will be God come to save us. She says, everyone in Seattle is talking about it. Pat's face will not let up that I've offended his sense of aesthetic. Mistaking Miao for Meow, how could I have been so careless?
从公寓的样子看，我本不会猜到帕特是个讲究细节的人。莎莉说：“缪说如果有飞船下来接我们，我们应该上去，因为那是上帝来拯救我们。她说西雅图每个人都在谈论这个。”帕特脸上显出我冒犯了他审美情趣的不悦。把缪（Miao）误听成喵（Meow），我怎么能这么大意？
I use the notion of God's Holy Spaceship to lure Pat back into the confines of deference and civility. Pat, I say, will you get on God's Holy Spaceship when it comes? Get on it, he says, no. I might get in it, but I'm not riding on top. Sally asks if I will get on God's Holy Spaceship. I tell it depends on who else is getting on. What do you mean, she asks? Well, I'm not going to board willy-nilly, I say. What if my upstairs neighbor gets on? That man raises pit bulls. I'm not getting on with that. I tell her that if I see, say, Oprah Winfrey getting on, I might have a change of heart. Pat says, he would rather get on the superhighway and meet God there on own, rather than get on the spaceship, which like the bus, will only be a breeding ground for TB.
我利用“上帝神圣飞船”的概念来诱导帕特回到礼貌和客气的范围内。“帕特，”我说，“当上帝的神圣飞船来的时候，你会上去吗？”“上去？”他说，“不，我可能会进到里面，但我不会骑在上面。”莎莉问我是否会坐上帝的神圣飞船。我说这取决于还有谁上去。她问：“什么意思？”我说：“好吧，我可不会随随便便就登船。如果我的楼上邻居也上去怎么办？那家伙养了斗牛犬。我可不想跟他一起。”我告诉她，如果我看到奥普拉·温弗瑞（Oprah Winfrey）上去，我可能会改变主意。帕特说，他宁愿走超级高速公路在那里见上帝，也不愿坐那艘像公交车一样会成为肺结核温床的飞船。
He says, the spaceship will be for people who don't have computers, and that he will have his by the time God comes. He says, definitely, he will not get on God's Holy Spaceship if Rush Limbaugh is on. On the spaceship or on TV, I ask? Pat looks at me as though there were a horrible smell coming from my direction. Sally says, she will not get on God's Holy Spaceship if there is anything on TV, because that would mean that someone would still be left on Earth, and that she, Sally, would want to be the very last, last person to board God's Holy Spaceship.
他说，飞船是给那些没有电脑的人准备的，而上帝来的时候他会有自己的电脑。他说，如果拉什·林博（Rush Limbaugh）在船上，他绝对不会上去。我问：“是在飞船上还是在电视上？”帕特看着我，仿佛我身上散发出一股难闻的气味。莎莉说，如果电视上有什么节目她就不坐上帝的神圣飞船了，因为这意味着地球上还有人没走，而她，莎莉，想成为最后一个、最后一个登上上帝神圣飞船的人。
She asks, what if I can't see that Oprah already has her seat? This little game of, what if, is starting to depress me, and I announce to the table that I will not be boarding God's Holy Spaceship at all. Pat passes from behind me on his way into the kitchen and detectably mutters, as if anyone cares.
她问：“如果我没看见奥普拉已经坐下了怎么办？”这场关于“如果”的小游戏开始让我感到沮丧，我向餐桌宣布，我根本不会乘坐上帝的神圣飞船。帕特从我身后经过走进厨房，嘟囔了一句：“好像谁在乎似的。”
What do you mean, you won't be getting on God's Spaceship, Sally asks. There is an element of fear in her concern for my salvation. I tell her, I mean that if Wicker Park gets on God's Holy Spaceship, I won't be. But nobody else would be here, Sally deduces. You'd have to get high all by yourself. Yes. But if nobody were left in Wicker Park, you'd have to go all the way to Humboldt Park to get your dope.
“你什么意思，你不打算坐上帝的飞船？”莎莉问。她的担忧中带着一丝对我的救赎的恐惧。我说，我的意思是，如果威克公园（Wicker Park）的所有人都上了上帝的神圣飞船，那我就不去了。莎莉推断说：“但那就没人留在这里了。你只能一个人吸大麻了。”“是的。但如果威克公园一个人都没有了，你就得一直走到洪堡公园（Humboldt Park）去买大麻。”
I tell her if there were no one in Wicker Park, then I'd be high on life, and I wouldn't need a bag of dope. Sally is offended by this somehow. And I spend after dinner time in the kitchen helping with dishes as a gesture of goodwill and gratitude for the future bowl of hooch we will share in the living room, after I have persuaded Pat to change the music.
我告诉她，如果威克公园空无一人，那我会因为生活本身而感到兴奋（high），就不需要那一袋大麻了。莎莉不知为何对此感到被冒犯了。晚餐后，我在厨房洗碗，作为一种善意和感激的姿态，为了将来能在客厅共享那碗“好货”，在我劝说帕特换掉音乐之后。
I ask Sally probing questions about her childhood and family. I feign interest in her affairs, her many, many affairs, one right after another. An endless stream of half-night romances with this bartender, that bartender, this cab driver, that cab driver, this paramedic, that paramedic. I imagine Sally's service is readily available to any adventurous commuter on God's Holy Spaceship who would offer her a smile.
我问了莎莉一些关于她童年和家庭的探究性问题。我假装对她的私生活感兴趣，她那些一个接一个的私生活。无穷无尽的露水情缘：这个酒保，那个酒保，这个出租车司机，那个出租车司机，这个护理人员，那个护理人员。我想象着，对于上帝神圣飞船上任何对她报以微笑的冒险通勤者来说，莎莉的服务都是唾手可得的。
You're crazy about God's Spaceship Cheryl, she says. You better get on with God. I imagine Sally getting on with God. I follow her into the living room where Pat hangs like a bat from a bar on the rack off the ceiling. I wonder why he's doing this just after eating. Sally and I sit on the couch. She picks up the classified section of the Reader and scans the personals leisurely but with intent.
“你对上帝的飞船很着迷啊，谢丽尔，”她说，“你最好还是跟上帝一起上船吧。”我想象着莎莉跟上帝一起上船的情景。我跟着她走进客厅，帕特像只蝙蝠一样吊在天花板的单杠上。我想知道他为什么要刚吃完饭就这么做。莎莉和我坐在沙发上。她拿起《读者》杂志的分类广告版，悠闲但有目的地浏览着征友栏。
I wonder why she's invited me over. Where was this alleged bag of P-O-T? I light cigarettes to drop the hint that something needed to get burning. I dropped the hint that I had very bad, bad cramps. Sally asks Pat to get me some Advil from the bathroom. You get it, he says, I'm hanging. You get it, Pat, Sally says, I'm reading.
我想知道她为什么要邀请我过来。那袋所谓的大麻在哪？我点燃香烟暗示该点火了。我暗示我痛经非常严重。莎莉让帕特去卫生间给我拿些雅维（Advil）。“你自己去拿，”他说，“我正吊着呢。”“你去拿，帕特，”莎莉说，“我在看东西。”
Pat crunches himself up quickly 50 times before disengaging himself from the rack. He executes a midair flip to get down and tells me I wouldn't have such bad cramps if I got more exercise. I follow him to the bathroom, which has no door on it. A beach towel drapes the entrance. He pops the top off the Advil container and asks how many, one or two? 12.
帕特迅速做了50个仰卧起坐，才从单杠上下来。他做了一个空中翻转落地，告诉我如果我多运动就不会痛经那么严重。我跟着他去卫生间，那门没装，门口挂着一条沙滩巾。他打开雅维瓶盖，问要吃几粒，一颗还是两颗？12颗。
In the living room, Pat changes the music to something a little more subtle, ambient industry noise. Cheryl darling, will you get me Pat's jacket from the coat tree in the hall? Yes, pet, of course. A shift is taking place, we are rounding the bend. I pretend I don't know or care that Sally must be sending me to retrieve something very special from Pat's jacket. I pretend it's the farthest thing from my mind that I am about to get very, very high. Pat's jacket, in the hall? I don't see it. Oh, this jacket?
在客厅里，帕特把音乐换成了更微妙的东西，一种环境工业噪音。“亲爱的谢丽尔，能帮我从门厅的衣架上拿一下帕特的夹克吗？”“好的，宝贝，当然。”情况正在发生转变，我们要进入正题了。我假装不知道也不关心莎莉一定是想让我从帕特的夹克里取回什么特别的东西。我假装我完全没想过我马上就要变得非常非常嗨。“帕特的夹克，在门厅？我没看见。”“哦，是这件夹克吗？”
Sally takes the jacket and pulls out what I have been waiting for. Oh, yes. She tells me it's hydroponic and that a little goes a long way. I understand. She pinches off a bit of it for the bong, a four foot water pipe the landlord, Sally tells me, left over during one of his last project days a month ago.
莎莉接过夹克，拿出了我一直在等待的东西。哦，是的。她告诉我这是水培的，一点点就很管用。我懂了。她摘了一小块放进烟枪里，那是房东一个月前在他最后一次装修项目期间留下来的四英尺水烟壶。
Cheryl darling, she says again, as if the use of darling could make any more attractive what she was about to offer me. Yes, pet? Did you know a dog will lick for hours anything spread with peanut butter? Her pretty little pixie face stuns me. Really? Peanut butter, fascinating. Oh yes, she says. Bundy, she calls. And from the other room jogs in a black dog, with a mix of doberman and rottweiler.
“亲爱的谢丽尔，”她又说了一次，好像用“亲爱的”就能让她要给我的东西变得更有吸引力似的。“怎么了，宝贝？”“你知道狗会花几个小时舔涂了花生酱的任何东西吗？”她漂亮的小精灵面孔惊呆了我。“真的吗？花生酱，真有意思。”“哦，是的，”她说。“邦迪，”她喊道。从另一个房间跑进来一条黑狗，混合了杜宾和罗威纳血统。
I watch Sally light and suck up the bong. She holds it in and blows it out all over Bundy's face. Hello boy, she says, and lets him wash her face with dog kisses. Cheryl darling, she says again. Yes, pet. I'm not going to get you high until you promise to get on with me and God in the spaceship.
我看着莎莉点火并吸了一大口烟枪。她含在嘴里，然后吹得邦迪满脸都是。“你好，伙计，”她说，让它用狗吻洗她的脸。“亲爱的谢丽尔，”她又说了一次。“怎么了，宝贝？”“除非你答应和我以及上帝一起坐那艘飞船，否则我不会让你嗨的。”
I should have seen it coming. Oh, pet. Are we still on that tired routine? Pat sits in an armchair, reading with focus and vigor the pages of an Interview magazine. With his fixed gaze, he strikes an uncanny resemblance to Captain Picard deep in thought. I try not to look at him or the beautiful bud Sally has placed in a Ricola tin on the coffee table. I try not to think of myself on God's Holy Spaceship with Sally as my bunk mate, the endless nights up talking, giggling, Sally recounting the many stewards she had screwed that day. How could it get any worse? I wonder if sometimes I am too much of a snob. Well, why wouldn't Sally make a wonderful bunk mate? All bugs are not cockroaches, all bugs are not cockroaches, I think to myself. Oh, pet, really. Well, if it'll make you happy. Good, Sally says. Pat will you bring me the jar of Skippy from the kitchen? I want to show Cheryl something.
我早该预料到的。“哦，宝贝。我们还在玩那个陈词滥调吗？”帕特坐在扶手椅上，专注且充满活力地读着《Interview》杂志。他那凝视的目光，让他看起来极其神似沉思中的皮卡德船长。我尽量不去看他，也不去看莎莉放在咖啡桌上利口乐糖盒里那美丽的芽。我尽量不去想自己和莎莉作为铺位伙伴在上帝神圣飞船上的情景，深夜聊天、咯咯笑，莎莉讲述她那天勾引了多少空乘。还能再糟吗？我怀疑自己有时是不是太势力了。好吧，为什么莎莉不能成为一个很棒的铺位伙伴呢？不是所有的虫子都是蟑螂，不是所有的虫子都是蟑螂，我对自己说。“哦，宝贝，好吧。如果这能让你开心的话。”“太好了，”莎莉说，“帕特，能从厨房把那罐Skippy花生酱拿给我吗？我想给谢丽尔看点东西。”
Cheryl Trykv performing at the Hothouse, back in the day.
谢丽尔·特里夫（Cheryl Trykv）早年曾在Hothouse表演。
Our show is produced by Peter Clowney, Delores Wilber, Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and myself. And contributing editors are Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Paul Tough. We broadcast from WBEZ in Chicago.
我们的节目由彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）、多洛雷斯·威尔伯（Delores Wilber）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）、艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和我自己制作。特约编辑是杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）。我们从芝加哥WBEZ电台播出。
Hey, you know, let's get some music up here. Hold on. Let's hear you little music. There we go.
嘿，你知道吗，来点音乐。等等。让我们听听音乐。好的，就是这样。
We broadcast from WBEZ Chicago. Now to review our little contest that we announced at the beginning of the show. You are to use all of the words that are seen as desirable words in referring to Democrats. You are to use them all in one sentence, those words. If you have pencil and paper they are, sick, traitors, corrupt, bizarre, cheat, steal, devour, self-serving, and criminal rights. And also get the word Democrat in there, will you please?
我们从芝加哥WBEZ电台播出。现在回顾一下我们在节目开始时宣布的小比赛。你要用所有被视为指代民主党人时令人向往的词汇。你要把这些词全部用在一句话里。如果你有笔和纸，它们是：恶心的、叛徒、腐败的、怪异的、作弊、偷窃、吞噬、自私的和犯罪权利。还有，请把“民主党人”这个词也加进去，好吗？
And the address to send that to, Your Radio Playhouse WBEZ, 848 East Grand Avenue, Chicago, Illinois, 60611. Our email address for this very contest, or anything else you want to say, [email protected] .
发送地址是：Your Radio Playhouse WBEZ, 848 East Grand Avenue, Chicago, Illinois, 60611。我们这个比赛，或者你想说的任何其他话，电子邮件地址是：[email protected]。
[ACKNOWLEGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]